- Today, we're making Hanukkah crafts.
- And ruining perfectly good mason jars.
(light music)
- If you don't hate yourself
by the end of the Pinterest,
it's not a Pinterest.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I don't know what I'm
doing actually to be honest.
- You're just painting popsicle sticks
and gluing them together.
It's like not reinventing the wheel here.
(laughing)
- I would totally date a guy
completely covered in metallic paint.
- I'm almost completely
covered in metallic paint.
- Wow.
- My hand is.
- Today is your lucky day, sir.
(laughing)
- I've never met a glue gun I didn't hate.
- I should not be as
frustrated as I am right now.
- No.
- I'm glad that you're going ahead of me
because then I can look at you
and decide what I don't want to do.
- So good
and by so good I mean I messed it up.
- Oh my God, look at yours.
- It's a beauty, right?
- It's so blinged out.
- Ding.
- That looks beautiful.
- Thanks.
- Mine, I don't know.
- They're just beautiful different stars.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Next to each other.
Best friends.
- BFFs.
- When I get to the final step
and I find out I glued
the wrong fucking side.
There's a rage inside me
that I haven't felt in a long time.
- [Voiceover] It's all about lights.
- All about lights.
- We're just making one fancy light.
- This feels like
preschool all over again.
- Just going to take my glue,
put it on there and just.
- I want to start with
the darkest at the bottom
and then go lighter as you go up.
- See, you're crafty.
- I am so--
- You're doing it.
- Yay.
- Honestly too, if somebody
brought this to my house
and they're like, look what I made you,
I'd be like, you need to take that back.
You need to take that home with you.
- Yeah, look at this shit, dude.
Feel like I was Leonardo
da Vinci in another life.
♫ If you got something
♫ And you don't really like it
♫ Just put a lid clear on it ♫
- My plan is to just keep
gluing and keep covering
and eventually I'll die.
- I covered mine with glitter.
- This isn't my best work.
I'll say that.
- My wife would be very proud.
- I think your wife would
be very proud of me.
- Eh.
- Just looking at this one,
I think this is hard to fuck up.
I'm going to put that out
there in the beginning.
- I'm going to hope.
- Why is it hard to cut straight lines?
- Right now I'm overlapping my dreidels
so that I'm making one mega dreidel.
- I like how three dimensional
this is going to be.
This is kind of cool.
- Look at that.
That is,
that looks horrible.
- I wouldn't even try
to show this to my mom.
- Actually now that football's leaving,
I'm going to need
something to do on Sundays.
- We have a dog.
- We have really fucked up stars.
- That's beautiful.
That looks really good.
- Don't you lie to me, Curly.
- I swear.
Well, look at this.
This looks like a plain Jane.
You're like her sexy hot friend.
- I really feel like
half the stuff we made,
you could buy for a dollar or two.
Did not have to make it.
It's not like we're making anything
that saves you a lot of money.
- I had a good time
hanging out with Curly.
- Yeah, it was great.
This was fun.
- That's what it is, right?
It's the social aspect of doing crafts.
- We had quality Hanukkah making time.
- Holidays are all about
bringing family together
and we brought two friends together
to make crafts.
- Ow.
- There.
(laughs) There's a nose hole.
- Happy Hanukkah.
- Oh, ew.